All right so we're going to talk about a
particular kind of function approximator
here that we refer to as an averager and
the whole class of averager
function approximators.
>> Okay.
>> So this is a kind of function
approximator that was actually or
at least in this context
introduced by Jeff Gordon and
when he did it there was this sort of
collective head slapping that happened
over the entire community of
reinforcement learning researchers.
Because it was just there.
It was so beautiful and
nobody saw it except for him.
And so it really was at that time,
the age of Gordon.
>> [LAUGH] That's fantastic.
>> So moving on.
So we're going to introduce this
averages concept in the context
of a simple example.
So imagine that we're trying to do is
represent a function over the line.
So over the over this
one dimensional space.
So it's going to be some
kind of curve [SOUND] And
the parameters that we're going to
get to set are the actual value of
that function at some particular point.
So at X1, at X2, and at X3 we can,
you know, move these up and
down, these points.
And what we'd like is that we
define a function approximator so
that once we've defined these points,
the rest of them will get kind
of filled in in a natural way.
Let's say.
And for this story to make
sense they're going to have
to somehow be related to averaging
>> Sure.
>> How do we define the value of
points in between here between x1 and
x to say we want to get going to get
the value of some point Just plain old x
as a function of the value at x1 and
the value of x2.
Yeah.
So so
what would be a natural way to do that?
I know you can say more than
one if you can think of it.
>> Sure there's lots ways of doing it
but I guess the simplest one would be
just to take our weighted
average based on distance.
>> Yes which is why these
things are called Averagers.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to say okay the value of x I don't
know what it is, but we're always
going to make sure it's, I don't know,
0.8 times the value of x1,
which is a parameter,
plus 0.2 times the value at x2,
which is another one of our parameters.
>> And that's because of the relative
distance between Vx1 and x2.
>> Yeah, so
it turns out it doesn't matter but
that is a very natural thing to do.
To kind of do a linear interpolation.
And so what that means is once you
nail down where x1, x2, and x3 are.
The way that it generalizes,
the way that it fills in the rest of the
function is like little line segments.
There's a bunch of other
things you could do and
they're all okay as long as what we do
is any point that we want to define,
we define it as a convex
combination of the anchor points.
So the anchor points are the ones that
we get to set as free parameters and
the value at any other state needs to be
expressible as a convex combination of
the anchor points.
So this doesn't really tell
us what should we do for
beyond x3 for things that
are out here in the state space.
>> Well that's funny.
That is just what I
was going to ask you.
What we do for
extrapolation instead of interpolation?
>> Yeah, so this is very interpolative.
[LAUGH] Is that a word?
>> It is now.
>> Interpolative,
it's sort of interpolation related.
So the constraint that we've got.
For it to be an averager, it needs
to be that the value of any point
is the convex combination
of a set of anchor points.
So, we get to define how
things extrapolate but
it has to be the case that for
example for some point X prime out here,
its value needs to be defined in terms
of these black points, in terms of
the these other anchor points whose
values are going to get to be set.
So, one natural thing would be to say
okay,we're out to the right of X1.
Let's just set anything out
here to be the value of X3.
>> Sure.
>> So we don't really extrapolate so
much as just you know flick
flatten it out on the two ends.
So we don't get too kind of crazy up or
down from from where we were but there's
other things that we could do as well
you could also say that if you're far
enough away from the points then it's
going to be the average the just
straight up average of these guys.
And as you get closer it's going to
be more influenced by the near ones.
By virtue of the fact that
it's a convex combination.
What does that tell us
about the value out here?
>> Well, it has to be in between
the highest and lowest value.
That's for sure.
>> Exactly.
That's right.
So we are extrapolating, but
we're not really extrapolating
outside of the data that we've got.
>> Okay.
>> And this is,
this is going to be a really
important property.
These averages to make sure that
they're going to be well behaved.
Right?
So that, that makes sense so far?
>> Yeah.
>> Do I have a good definition
of an average or?
>> I think you do